I like people yeah they're just not my
favorite animal I don't worry about
being dead I won't know about it that's
the best thing about being dead it's
like being stupid it's only painful for
others if there is a God why did he make
me an atheist that was his first mistake
do you mind if I masturbate to to commit
suicide is is denying grace of God [ __ ]
off so when your working class mum Jesus
is like an unpaid babysitter I'm an
atheist I don't believe in about 2,700
God's Christians don't believe in two
thousand six hundred and ninety-nine so
they're nearly as atheistic as moon yes
it doesn't matter what's happening in
the real world how good life is if
you're not happy in there it doesn't
matter you're not happy I'm I'm a year
closer to death than last time I saw him
Twitter is like being able to read every
toilet wall in the world a dog it's
[ __ ] amazing it's 15 years of joy and
then terrible sadness I love Jesus
it was my superhero religion is enormous
it is when it's when your God starts
telling you that you should kill
homosexuals if everyone died in their
sleep
what would we fear we've cut we'd enjoy
every single day knowing that one day we
wouldn't wake up just because you're
offended it doesn't mean you're right if
you're born in India you're probably a
Hindu if you're born in America you're
probably a Christian you're born in
Pakistan if probably a Muslim that's a
coincidence isn't it you always born
into the right God always and that lucky
I was born into the right God all those
others are going to hell but I was born
into the right religion I'm going to
heaven
I'm not gay in fact I can honestly say
I've never come over a little queer I
love everywhere in the world because
wherever you go people are all the same
it's not easy being green someone
somewhere in the world will find what
you say offensive so what who cares
don't worry day you're gonna ask me how
I am and I'm literally just gonna be
dead in the chair